foreign
[Music]
looking to jump start your ml project
don't know where to start or what model
is right for you well why not start your
ml project in model Garden on vertex AI
watch this video to learn more about
vertex AI model Garden
first just a quick recap vertex AI is a
fully managed ml platform on Google
Cloud
verbex AI allows you to access build
experiment deploy and manage models you
may be doing traditional data science
machine learning mlops or simply
building an AI powered app and vertex AI
will support all of those workloads more
recently we've announced two major tools
for you to do even more model garden and
generative AI studio so in this video
we'll dive into model Garden
so what is vertex AI model Garden
model Garden is a single place to
discover and interact with Google's
industry-leading models and popular open
source models with Google Cloud's
Enterprise mlops tooling support built
in
with all these different Enterprise
ready models you could use model Garden
allows you to choose the right model for
your use case ml expertise and budget
from monogarden you can kick off a
variety of workflows including using a
model directly as an API tuning the
model in the genitive AI Studio
using the model directly in a jupyter
notebook through vertex AI workbench or
help you deploy model training pipelines
so let's explore this topic a bit so as
a developer you may want to start with
pre-trained models that are ready to use
out of the box
finding relevant models and being able
to use them quickly becomes a way to
accelerate your time to getting value
let's explore some models on model
garden and walk through what the
experience might look like
alright let's explore how I can use pom2
for text
clicking on view details brings us to
the model card which gives us more
details about the pom2 model for text
and there's even a button at the top
that shows us how to use it directly
and this brings us to the generative AI
Studio
generative AI Studio enables you to
interact with the model via a simple UI
or tune the model with your own data
let's explore the Palm 2 model for text
so I can ask something like explain
large language models like I'm 5. and it
gives me an explanation of llms
with the Palm family of models you can
prototype in genitive AI Studio but for
other models that aren't in generative
AI Studio you can interact with them via
a notebook let's walk through an example
as a data scientist where instead of
starting from scratch I'll start by
looking in model Garden to see if there
is an existing model that fits my use
case around text and images
so I want to see if model Garden has
computer vision models that I can
explore
from the model Garden page let's filter
for vision related models next let's
select detection tasks
great there's an owl Vision Transformer
model an open source model and it says
it's a zero shot text conditioned object
detection model that can query an image
with one or more multiple text queries
let's dive into this
so clicking on view details here we see
the model card where we can see more
details
as a data scientist I may want to try
using this at this point so I'll click
on open notebook
this opens up a collab notebook for the
owl Vision Transformer model I can then
walk through this notebook to learn more
about how to get started understanding
my image files
so this notebook in particular shows how
I can deploy this open source model to
an endpoint on vertex AI then send an
image to the endpoint to get a
prediction which is a text caption
describing what's in the image so that
flow from finding a model to deploying
and using it becomes super easy with
model Garden
here's another way that makes using
models easy on vertex AI model Garden
for some models like Bert you may want
to fine tune the model by supplying it
with your own data
I think so it might take a series of
complicated steps on your own but mono
Garden makes it easier by wrapping it in
a pipeline for you to quickly use with
minimal or zero coding
let me click on open fine tuning
pipeline
this brings me to a pipeline template
that I can use to fine tune and deploy
this model
you can see the various components of
the pipeline that this template would
execute
to use the pipeline I can click on
create run
then I proceed to enter in the required
parameters like where I want to store
any outputs of my pipeline as well as
the input parameters like where my
training data is and then just click
submit
then with that it will Kickstart My
pipeline I didn't have to write any code
so that's vertex AI model Garden
enabling you to search discover and
interact with a wide variety of curated
and Enterprise ready models for more
information check out the link below
foreign